in this video we'll be talking about
multiple sclerosis this is a High video
for usml step
one multiple sclerosis simply means
multiple Scar and all this scar happens
throughout the spinal cord and the
central nervous system so there are many
lesions that accumulate over
time so Ms results from Progressive
demin of the mine sheath in the neurons
of the central nervous system so the
question is why there is a demyelination
because the immune systems start
reacting against these mine Sheed which
ultimately results in demyelination
there are Auto antibodies which
recognize many proteins which are
present in the myin Sheed and they react
against it thereby destroying this
mation in this video we'll be talking
about broadly four topics but the focus
would be on pathology
so first we'll be talking about the
clinical presentation second we'll be
talking about the pathophysiology of the
multiple sclerosis third we'll be
talking about diagnosis and ultimately
we'll talk about treatment and
management so let's talk about the
clinical symptoms of multiple
sclerosis so this particular disease
does not affect the peripheral nervous
system so the key nerves that are
affected are the optic and the ocul
motor nerves also the spinal nerve tract
can be affected very much the symptoms
of multiple sclerosis is quite variable
all the symptoms doesn't occur in all
the patients so there are vision
problems which are very common about 40%
patient show that this kind of problem
there are numb numbness tingling walking
difficulty which are also very common in
these multiple sclerosis sclerosis
patients there could be additionally
dizziness weakness fat fatigue cognitive
dysfunction but all these things appear
in a variable percentage in different
type of patients based on their
ethnicity and the geographical location
they belong
to but there are some common criteria to
classify multiple sclerosis this
includes disartria that means difficulty
and unclear speech Scar and this happens
due to the scars in the brain stem there
could be nagas that means involuntary
and rapid eye movement and there are
also lesion in the optic and oculomotor
nerve so there are problems there could
be blurred
vision there could be double vision as
well and also there is intention tremor
which arise due to lesion in the motor
pathway all these three symptoms
together is known as the sharos
Triad multiple sclerosis pathol
pathology is characterized by confluent
demyelinated areas throughout the
central nervous system this is how a
coronal section of a healthy brain look
like and this is how a Ms brain look
like already you can see there are many
uh lesions that can present that can be
present in the cortical region cortical
demyelination is pretty common alongside
there there could be white matter
demyelination as
well and this de demyelination where the
milein is damaged the conduct
action velocity of the neuron is
affected because milin Sheed works like
an insulator for any
neuron these kind of lesions can be
detected using magnetic resonance
imaging this is a reference where you
can see there are multiple lesions
marked by these yellow
arrows now let's talk about the risk
factors there could be genetic and
environmental risk factors let's talk
about the environmental risk factors
first it turns out that women are more
susceptible compared to men when it
comes to Ms but why there could be
immunological differences there could be
body fat and genetical differences there
could be also hormone related
differences which might account to these
kind of
changes and also geography is a big deal
because places where sunlight is
limiting for example in the northern
part of America and Russia the risk of
my the RIS RIS of multiple sclerosis is
very high so vitamin D is somehow
correlated with the risk of multiple
sclerosis and it has been now shown in
many
studies so just to summarize it is more
common in females than males and it is
more common in areas which has uh low
sunlight incidence so here comes the
genetic factors there are more than 200
risk Gene variants associated with
multiple sclerosis are diagnosed most of
these Varian encode molecules which are
involved in the immune system or
modulation of the immune
system this includes HLA genes present
on chromosome 6 especially including HLA
drb1 and these polymorphism is
associated with multiple sclerosis also
polymorphism associated with il2 and il7
receptors are associated with multiple
sclerosis and this particular review
shows a bunch of risk factors including
genetic and environmental risk factors
associated with multiple sclerosis one
of the important factor to note that
there could be viruses which are which
whose infection can be associated with
multiple sclerosis for example ipin bar
Virus Infection is highly associated
with multiple sclerosis which is found
by recent studies also as we have talked
about that low level of vitamin D has a
strong correlation with the hazard of
relapse in multiple sclerosis now when
it comes to classification of multiple
sclerosis there are different types such
as relapsing remitting or rrms there
could be secondary Progressive multiple
sclerosis primary Progressive and
Progressive relapsing Multiple Sclerosis
in relapsing remitting Multiple
Sclerosis which is also the most common
type bouts of autoimmune attack happens
in span of years or months in secondary
Progressive multiple sclerosis there is
a steady progression of the disability
in case of primary Progressive there is
a constant attack of on the myin Sheed
which lead to a steady progression of
the disease and this is the most
dangerous part and in case of
progressive relapsing there there is a
constant attack but sometimes the attack
even uh become more intense so the last
two are more severe form of multiple
sclerosis now let's talk about the
immunological basis of multiple
sclerosis so when it comes to T T cells
th17 subtype of T cell and th1 cells are
highly associated with multiple
sclerosis these are autoreactive t-
cells but why they are generated because
in normal cases there are Central
tolerance and peripheral tolerance
mechanism which can prevent the
generation of any autoactive te- cells
but how come in multiple sclerosis they
are generated so obviously there is a
failure in these autoa in preventing
these autoactive te- cells anyway these
autoreactive tea cells eventually cross
the blood brain barrier and enter the
brain and they can do many things inside
the brain including secreting
inflammatory cyto which would ultimately
increase the brain
inflammation so question is how
autoreactive te- cells are generated
obviously the central tolerance
mechanism the peripheral tolerance
mechanism might break down and that is
why these autoactive te- cells are
generated it's also possible T
regulatory cells
which prevent in inflammation they also
break down that's why there is nobody to
suppress the inflammatory cell
types ultimately the outcome is
increased production of th17 and th1
cells which inate the brain
eventually and these cells can cause
several problems inside the brain
however there are now new research which
shows that IL 17 secreting th7 cells are
highly associated with multiple
sclerosis patient
brain now let's talk about the overall
summary of the immunological context in
multiple sclerosis immune cells
generally infiltrate from the periphery
to the brain especially there are
activation of circulating CSF
lymphocytes which are very predominant
in case of multiple sclerosis also the
CNS is inherited by microa and
astrocytes also the state of these
microglia and asites becomes more
reactive so overall these immunological
factors make it more worse in case of
multiple sclerosis CNS derived soluble
antigens are carried in the CSF across
the nasal mucosa and ultimately drains
into the lymph node so obviously the
lymph node becomes swellen sometimes in
the multiple sclerosis all these
information are provided in these
reviews whose link is provided in the
description anyway there are specific
proteins on the myin sheath known as
myin B basic protein or PLP or MOG all
these proteins are not supposed to be
detected by the te helper cells because
they are self proteins but it turns out
in Ms brain all these proteins are
detected and that creates a problem then
these particular autoreactive T cells
start secreting and differentiating into
th1 and th17 cells which secrete further
inflammatory cyto mines like intercine 1
6 TGF beta Etc which overall increase
the inflammation in the entire brain and
the nervous
system now however the importance of th1
subtype versus th17 subtype in context
of multiple sclerosis is unknown and
it's still subject to
debate but people strongly believe that
there is a failure of the regulatory T
cells to suppress these autoreactive te-
cells and that is why the immune system
goes haare in case of multiple
sclerosis now there are many clinically
relevant biomarkers which are discovered
for multiple sclerosis all of these are
basically CSF derived biomarkers so
after Lumber puncture followed by
proteomic studies found that my myin
basic protein IGM oligoclonal bands uh
neural cell addition molecules or en
camps osteopontin then cxcl13 all of
these proteins can serve as important
biomarker for multi multiple sclerosis
all these biomarkers can also be
monitored in early stage of the disease
uh progression so the prognosis might be
better if we consider these biomarkers
for diagnosis other than biomarkers
there are classical clinical MRIs which
are really important and confirmatory
for these kind of uh multiple sclerosis
diagnosis one can clearly understand
there would be multiple lesions in the
brain as seen here marked by the yellow
circles there is no treatment for
available for multiple sclerosis there
is no cure for multiple sclerosis
however all the uh symptoms such as
physical weakness numbness these can be
treated with the supportive medication
physiotherapy can make things better and
I hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
Please share my channel link with your
friends and let me know in the comments
how do you like my videos you can
support our Channel using super thanks
see you in next
[Music]
video